. So, OK, up first, this process.
Will Republicans be able to confirm a justice
to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg before the
election on November 3rd, before the January
20th inauguration?
Time wise, 45.
Days, which is what we have roughly remaining
between now and the November 3rd election.
That's very fast.
Typically, it takes about 70 days from nomination
to confirmation for a Supreme Court justice.
So it would be very tough to do it in the
45 days before the election.
But it could happen.
Donald Trump reportedly going to nominate
a replacement for Ruth Bader Ginsburg this
week.
The bigger question to me is the lame duck
period.
If it I don't know that they need to necessarily
do it before the election, because I believe
that even if Joe Biden were to win, they will
have the time and potentially the ability,
potentially the power, potentially the support
to install a replacement for Ruth Bader Ginsburg
during the interim period, the lame duck period
between November 3rd, 4th and January 20th.
Now, do they have the votes?
You need 51 votes to confirm a Supreme Court
justice or you need 50 votes, plus the tie
breaking vote from the vice president, which
they would have in Mike Pence for sure.
Republicans have a political situation to
contend with because Republicans are defending
25 of the 38 Senate seats that are on the
ballot.
Many of their more vulnerable members have
been eager to get back home, get out of D.C.,
expected to to be around mid-October.
I forget the exact date and campaign and that
would shorten the pre-election period.
It's not really 45 days.
It's more like 30 or 35 days because 30 really,
maybe even top 25, because they are planning
to end this session in mid-October.
Now, some of those senators might realize
not only that they need to get back and campaign
because their seats are at risk, but that
pushing forward on this before the election
could actually be bad for their reelection.
The balance right now in the Senate is 53
Republicans and 47 Democrats.
That's 45 Democrats, plus two independents,
Angus King and Bernie Sanders, who caucus
with Democrats.
So what they need.
Those of us what we need who oppose Donald
Trump getting to replace RB, RPG is we need
four Republican senators to say no.
Now, very early, there was this suspicion
or there were rumors that Mitt Romney wasn't
going to do this before the inauguration.
That was almost immediately refuted by campaign
staff.
Now, maybe Romney wouldn't do it.
We don't know yet.
The early claims that were made were were
merely rumors.
We then heard from Alaska Republican Senator
Lisa Murkowski, who put out a very carefully
worded statement saying that, quote, I did
not support taking up a nomination eight months
before the 2016 election to fill the vacancy
created by the passing of Justice Scalia.
We are now even closer to the 2020 election,
less than two months out.
And I believe the same standard must apply.
So certainly Lisa Murkowski is a No.
Before the election.
But there is nothing here.
And this is why you have to look at the wording.
There's nothing here that says if Trump loses,
she may still go forward with a vote to confirm
during what would be a lame duck period for
Donald Trump.
That's really the question mark.
Otherwise, we really aren't sure we can speculate.
Susan Collins.
OK.
Maybe she wouldn't go for it before the election.
But what about during the lame duck period?
Potential lame duck period.
Cory Gardner in Colorado.
He might realize this could be very bad for
his reelection.
But maybe during the lame duck period, we
don't know.
Maybe Martha McSally, who's down to Mark Kelly
in Arizona up.
We just don't know.
Now we have to look at the hypocrisy.
And the reason I'm kind of hesitating is they
don't care.
They don't care.
But, yes, they are hypocrites.
Look at some of these quotes from 2016 and
2018.
Senator Ted Cruz in 2016.
It has been 80 years since a Supreme Court
vacancy was nominated and confirmed in an
election year.
There is a long tradition that you don't do
this in an election year.
Hypocrite.
Lindsey Graham in 2018.
If an opening comes in the last year of President
Trump's term and the primary process has started,
we'll wait to the next election.
Marco Rubio, I don't think we should be moving
on a nominee in the last year of this president's
term.
I would say that if it was a Republican president.
Well, we're waiting, Marco.
Thom Tillis from North Carolina, Republican.
The campaign is already underway.
It is essential to the institution of the
Senate and to the very health of our republic
to not launch our nation into a partizan divisive
confirmation battle during the very same time
the American people are casting their ballot.
To elect our next president now, I could go
on and on with more and more of these.
But ultimately, trumpets have not punished
Republicans for heinous hypocrisy.
And I have no reason to believe that they
will this time.
Maybe some individual races could be affected.
But let's circle back around.
Is there anything positive here?
Because it seems like this is a disaster for
America, giving Trump the opportunity to ruin
things not just for four years, not merely
for eight years, but for decades.
The one thing that is very clear to me is
that this has the possibility to hugely and
energize Democratic voters, including left
leaning centrists, anti Trump moderates, and
even many of the never Biden left wingers
since Friday night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern, which
is when the world learned of the passing of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Small dollar donations have exploded to Democrats.
One hundred million dollars were donated in
the 40 or so hours following the death of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
People are reacting.
People are donating to Biden.
People are donating to Democrats nationally.
And I do believe this will increase voter
turnout, including early voting, which we
are already seeing.
What can we control here?
OK.
We can't make Republicans be consistent.
We can't make Republicans stop being hypocrites.
We can't make Republicans good moral people.
We can't control Trump.
But we can vote and we can lobby.
And we can donate and we can phone bank and
we can call our senators.
Let's focus on what we can do.
Let me know on Twitter.
What do you expect to see with this open seat?
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.